how to make more money
so i got a great uh question a while ago
i did a video of
somebody who who wanted to try to make
tons of money on ebay and he asked me
hey how do i
buy cheap products so i can sell them
for more on ebay and i said listen
that's not the answer because if you
don't love what you're doing if you're
just trying to make money
that's your only goal then you're not
going to make it ebay is not the
solution you have to find something that
you love and pull yourself into
that's the answer so i got a response
from one of my youtube
viewers loyal youtube viewer chefs tv
who wrote in to say
i would like to make some money so i can
invest into my business idea eventually
i don't believe i can be an ebay
millionaire like this person but what do
you think about doing this sort of stuff
short term so you can create enough
to pump into an idea so this is a really
really important question and it comes
down to your mindset
okay i don't know why we're trained this
way
but here so i look at chef's problem
okay he wants to build this
this is what he wants to build this is
his big idea this is his vision
and he thinks he's got to do all these
little things on the side
to be able to fund the big project okay
there's a couple challenges here
the first are these little things
if he doesn't love it if he's not
pouring himself into it if he's not
really enjoying and and adding value and
really
feeling it then it's not going to work
out the the
the businesses that you get into just
trying to make money
they don't work they don't work think
about how many times you've seen
somebody you know you read somebody they
made a million dollars on ebay or
they're buying these foreclosed homes
and fixing them up and selling them for
a profit and you think yeah i want to do
that i can do that i can see that guy on
tv
trading up and making all these deals i
could do that too
there's so much work guys that goes into
making these things happen you can't
just pick up
an ebook that cost you 97 bucks of
somebody's business idea and make it
work for you
because you have to love it you you're
gonna keep
you're gonna keep running around in
circles you're gonna be that hamster on
the wheel
running running running running running
and never get anywhere
never make any progress that's where
most people
get stuck that's where they live and
just
constant desperation constant
struggle to try to break free and you
just look for any money-making idea
but you never make it happen those
people never make it happen
and the answer is simples because you
don't love it you look at any famous
entrepreneur's story
look at how they got started and they
started with nothing a lot of times in
poverty
and they made it because they loved
their business and they believed in
themselves
you might be saying hey evan that's easy
for you you made your money you don't
have to worry about it
hey i'm the guy who is making 300 bucks
a month okay
below the poverty line turning down 100
000
a year jobs to focus on my business
where i didn't even know that was the
right thing to do and i constantly
doubted myself
i was so glad that i did it if you focus
this is where
99 of the world is you focus on this
thing
just trying to make money and come up
with any scheme to do it somebody
promise you get rich off some quick
stock you just focus on that stuff
it's never going to happen for you and
meanwhile we all have these dreams
right you have this dream for what you
want to accomplish you look at chefs he
has his dream this is what he wants to
build
and for some reason he's stuck on all
this crappy little tiny stuff
that never works if you have a dream
then you have to start going after that
dream now i don't know what it is for
chefs
his name is chef's tv maybe something to
do with tv maybe he wants to be a tv
star
tv producer i don't know but if you have
a dream that's what you need to go after
and start right now and and i get that
you may be struggling you know you have
bills to pay you have a mortgage you
have kids to look after
you know maybe you're you're a single
mom and your husband isn't paying his
child support because he's popping up on
pills whatever it is
i get that and you may be in that
survival mode
and you may have to take on crappy jobs
but if all you do is stay in survival
mode and never do something greater then
you're always going to be on that
hamster wheel and you're never going to
build this thing up
if you don't have any money right now
honestly the best thing to do
is go get a job that leads you towards
this
and yeah i'm saying go get i'm the
entrepreneur guy telling you to go get a
job
you know because you look at chef's tv
if he wants to be a
a tv producer have his own tv show if he
doesn't have any experience now doesn't
have any money now the best thing that
he can do
is go work for tv producing company
somebody who he looks up to can learn
from because he's going to give him
money
help him survive it's going to give him
contacts he's going to make mistakes
while getting paid to do it he's going
to learn the business
and everything he's doing is
gearing him towards making this big
project of his happen
where if all he does is get stuck trying
to sell ebay stuff and doing whatever
somebody else says will make them money
you're just constantly stuck in this
pattern never leads anywhere
so it's okay to go get a job to learn
it's okay to do your thing part time
and every big idea there are ways that
you can start
for free for nothing cheap just
your time you can break it down you have
this big vision what you want to
accomplish break that down into steps
and get started and do something every
day even if it's
20 minutes a day something every day to
make this happen
and stop worrying about this crap here
that's the difference
the people who just sit here never make
any money and get stuck
on life's treadmill and i don't want
that for you
and i don't know how to change the
mindset of people because we're so money
focused a lot and maybe it's because
you're
you know deep and dead or whatever it is
but if you stay here
this is all you think about you're never
gonna break free of this
never you need to find your path to get
to that big dream
and focus on it every single day i don't
care if it's full time but every day
you're taking action
to move forward on that dream even if it
means getting the job
to help support your path believe
for those of you watching like the video
give it a thumbs up below let me know
what you think leave a comment ask me a
question below
and you want to see more videos like
this subscribe by clicking on my face
thank you so much i'll see you soon